agent Hogan hadn't seen what had grabbed
the commander the sounds of blood
curdling screams had made his eyes
instinctively snap shut Hogan kept both
eyes tightly closed nothing but Darkness
blotting out his vision even as the
desperate Gravelly voiced yells of the
commander filled his ears then suddenly
there was a scream one that was abruptly
cut off with a heavy thud something
dropped to the ground close enough to
agent Hogan's feet that he could feel
the vibrations of it hitting the floor
through his boots it was the commander
completely still and Silent even though
he'd been trained to look danger in the
eye agent Hogan still didn't open his
eyes not even for a split second this
was the first time that anything like
this had ever happened and in the panic
and confusion his natural survival
instincts had overridden the SCP
foundation's various rules and protocols
in his head and right now something
thing was telling him not to look that
something was shifting and moving just
beyond agent Hogan's eyelids he could
hear a shuffling as something much
taller than an average human lumbered
around it had been wailing before
shrieking an uncontrollable and
inconsolable despair but now its cries
had lowered to a soft sobbing whimper
when someone's eyes are closed they
aren't completely cut off from the world
around them just being able to see does
an entirely dull a person's awareness
most people have a kind of sense a
spatial alert that tells them what's
nearby even if they can't see it and in
this particular moment agent Hogans was
going haywire the thing the thing Beyond
his closed eyes was moving towards him
so close he could feel its warm rancid
breath on his skin just knowing it was
so close hearing it breathe and SOB
gently sensing its standing being so
close to him it made the agents already
pounding heart rates start to climb he
could feel beads of sweat crawling down
the side of his face as the creature
leaned in closer it almost felt like it
was trying to goad him into opening his
eyes go on just take a peek came a
nagging gnawing voice at the back of
Hogan's mind he couldn't help it it was
a natural human response to be curious
but as intriguing of a sight as it might
have been the creature was far more
terrifying Hogan had no idea what horror
he'd be faced with if he even opened his
eyes for a second little did he know
forcing himself not to look whether out
of fear or pure survival Instinct had
saved the agent's life he could sense
the creature turn and start to slink off
getting further away again as it
lumbered around a corner on its
elongated legs still agent Hogan waited
a little longer before opening up his
eyes again just to be safe it had all
started around month earlier when the
SCP Foundation had discovered a
potential anomaly was being housed by a
group known as the department of
abnormalities you see back then the SCP
Foundation wasn't quite the sprawling
ginormous anomaly containment
organization some might be familiar with
it was far from being in its infancy at
this point in time either but the
foundation was only just beginning to
expand its collection of dangerous and
unusual anomalies they had received word
of an anomaly that was being held in a
facility in Stuttgart Germany where
Department of abnormalities Personnel
had gone to Great Lengths to secure it
however despite all the measures they
put in place this creature was able to
escape and didn't leave a single
Survivor in its wake after Breaking Free
and so being unfamiliar with this kind
of situation the SCP Foundation had to
decide what the best course of action
would be the foundation dispatched a
retrieval team codenamed Zulu 9A to the
facility the creature had broken free
from from the location in Stuttgart Zulu
9A was able to track the anomaly's
movements to an undisclosed mountainous
region it was believed that this area
was either the creature's natural
habitat where it had initially been
captured but that the mountain at least
closely resembled the place that the
anomaly would recognize as home flying
aboard a chopper the Zulu 9A team
assumed they could simply approach the
creature and calmly coerce it long
enough for them to capture and escort it
back to base it turned out they were
very very wrong as their Chopper landed
nearby and the retrieval team closed in
on the creature the captain of zulu 9A
turned to talk to a foundation doctor
that had accompanied the unit that one
serendipitous action might have saved
his life because it meant he wasn't
looking at the anomaly a sudden intense
shriek rang out as the creature started
crying turning towards the rest of the
approached retrieval unit in a panic
they pulled their triggers weapons
erupting into a hail of deafening
gunfire but it had no effect the
creature dashed towards them shrugging
off every oncoming attack completely
unscathed but the Zulu 9A team weren't
so well defended by the time the captain
turned back around the creature had
already vanished seemingly able to move
much faster than first anticipated maybe
once they'd taken a look at it the
retrieval team thought that the
creature's long disproportionate limbs
would make its movements clumsy and
cumbersome not that a single one of them
was left standing to verify that the
captain was left alone and stunned he
hadn't seen what had happened to his
team only the aftermath and it wasn't a
pretty sight before long backup arrived
in the form of zulu 9b's team with the
help of this secondary unit the captain
was able to eventually capture the
creature and remand it into SCP
Foundation containment how by placing a
bag over its head his theory was if it
couldn't see the retrieval team it
couldn't attack them and while this
strategy might have worked he was only
half right of course the SCP
foundation's mandate has always been to
contain and study the anomalies that it
encounters and this was all the more
prevalent during these earlier days of
the organization so naturally once the
creature had seemingly been captured and
secured a group of overzealous and eager
scientists were quick to step in so that
they could closely examine the anomaly
and for a time they were able to work
with little obstruction they could
determine the basic details about the
creature's physiology and have that
information logged in its very own file
on the SCP foundation's internal
database but one scientist made a very
fatal mistake during those early tests
and studies perhaps because the
foundation had already captured the
creature and secured it within the walls
of its own facility they believed it
posed no further threat to Personnel
anymore that it couldn't hurt to remove
the bag tag and take a closer look the
very instant the bag was removed chaos
broke loose it was as if someone had lit
the fuse of a firework only for it to
explode before they could rush to a safe
enough distance away not only were the
scientists studying the creature
horrified by the side of its grotesque
wide jawed face but they were all
seconds away from meeting the same grim
and grisly fate as the retrieval team
sent to capture it now they had seen its
face and the monster was loose within
the foundation at that particular point
in time the foundation's early mistakes
this kind of thing was unprecedented it
had never happened before not once and
nobody knew what to do most of the
anomalies they had encountered so far
were benign either harmless Oddities
passive and non-hostile creatures or
artifacts with a few strange or
unexplained properties but with no real
sentience to speak of but this was a
ferocious Abomination intent on harm to
the foundation's own staff so someone
needed to act and do so fast a handful
of armed Foundation agents happened to
be on site at the time security officers
Hendrix Hogan and Stevens as well as
Sutton the surviving captain from the
Zulu 9A retrieval team the second that
the creature was seen and began
retaliating against those that had seen
its face deafening alarms began to blare
that was all the warning they would get
there were no special containment
procedures yet no protocol or standard
procedure for something like this the
foundation didn't even have a term for
the situation that was going on although
after today they would this was the SCP
foundation's first ever Containment
Breach given that he'd been involved in
retrieving the creature that was now on
the loose Captain Sutton took lead of
the small group coordinating them as
their de facto Commander don't worry we
just need to get another bag over its
head and get it back into containment he
instructed as calmly and confidently as
he could given the tense circumstances
this thing is highly aggressive but if
you stay out of sight it won't come
after you corners and stay frosty we'll
split in tattoos and fan out should have
more of a chance of catching him that
way little did Sutton realize his
misguided advice would cost him and
others their lives Hendricks and Stephen
stumbled across the creature first
poking their heads around a corner they
spotted the tall Rye humanoid shape
passing along the corridor that ran
parallel to the one they stood in the
two agents saw the creature but as far
as they could tell it hadn't seen them
but that didn't matter just as they both
turned down the corner ready to Ambush
the anomaly the Towering spindly form of
the creature suddenly appeared behind
them screeching as it attacked hearing
the sound of the others falling prey to
the monster Captain Sutton and agent
Hogan Rush towards the source of their
fellow agents screams the de facto
commander of the group rushed a few
Paces ahead confident that he knew how
to get the upper hand against the
creature trailing behind him a agent
Hogan had been swept up in the Panic of
the whole situation he had no idea what
the creature was only that half of the
retrieval team sent to capture it had
all died their weapons were useless
against it which made the gun Hogan
gripped in his trembling fingers feel
unreassuringly ineffective Sutton turned
a corner down the corridor her head and
that had been when he locked eyes with
the creature seeing its face for the
first time he hadn't even caught a
proper glimpse of it when he'd managed
to capture it in the mountains but now
he had seen it and it knew from around
the corner unable to see Sutton or the
monster agent Hogan let the Panic at the
better of him and closed his eyes an
action that had unknowingly saved his
life once the monster had passed him by
and agent Hogan had dared to open his
eyes again his mind started racing it
had seen him that much he was certain of
even with his eyes closed he had sensed
just how close to him the creature had
gotten to him it had to have seen him in
yet he was still alive Sutton had said
that it would attack anyone that it saw
unless Sutton had got it all wrong the
creature wasn't attacking anyone it
looked at it was going after anyone who
looked at it it was learning that key
difference that allowed agent Hogan to
gain the upper hand on the creature
however he quickly realized that the
number of people in the facility was
rapidly dwindling the longer the anomaly
was able to roam free the more
Foundation Personnel would see its face
and fall victim to its rage agent Hogan
realized what he would have to do send
out a message to the SCP Foundation
higher-ups that this anomaly was only
attacking anyone who looked at it then
he sealed himself in the chamber where
the scientists had been examining the
creature they'd filmed the examination
all Hogan had to do was watch part of
the footage where the bag was removed
and look at the anomaly's face the
monster took care of the rest traveling
at impossible speeds
scp-096 appeared in the room behind
agent Hogan ever since the SCP
Foundation has poured innumerable
resources into ensuring they have enough
Personnel who are specifically trained
to deal with containment breaches some
will even tell you that it was this
first incident that led to the idea of
mobile task Forces teams at the
foundation can deploy within moments to
respond to anomalies breaking out of
their containment of course who really
knows if that is true maybe half of it
actually happened and the rest was built
off rumors and hearsay if you sign up to
join one of the SCP foundation's mobile
task forces nowadays then perhaps your
commanding officer will tell you this
story during your basic training it
could be that they're trying to
intimidate you or just re-emphasize how
important the role of the mtfs within
the foundation is one thing is for sure
though anyone assigned to guard as
cp096's chamber knows to close their
eyes in the event of another Containment
Breach now go and check out scp-096 the
shy guy CP animation and scp-096 is sad
end for more